you
members we're just waiting for
confirmation that the live feed is is
working we'll be back to you as soon as
we can
you
could I ask him one or two officers do
some running
it's working I just
Robin Wright members
welcome to Rockford district counsel was
at first remote council meeting and also
a warm welcome 20 residents who are
watching this evenings meeting via
livestream on accounts those YouTube
channel members in light of the recent
loss of accounts to Terry cut more
long-standing leader of roxxor district
council a more recently vice chairman of
the council and a former district
council councillor Jerry Gibson the
council will now observe a minute's
silence in their honor
thank you everybody
members you will know that councillor
Terry khatma was my vice chairman and I
shall greatly miss his wit and wisdom
especially when he sat next to me at the
right hand side of myself during council
meetings he was a lovely man a great
counselor and a regular winner of raffle
prizes I like many people here will
remember also Jerry Gibson who was
accounts of some years ago as a very
competent counselor and a great chairman
of the review committee would anybody
else members like to say anything before
we move on No Thank You members members
I would find it helpful during this
meeting to have some assistance and I
would like to move a motion that
counselor mrs. Carol Western acts as my
vice chairman during this meeting can I
ask for someone to second that please
Thank You Bryan Hazelwood councillor
Hayward thank you me but I would now ask
everybody if anybody is against this
motion to please click on their raised
hand icon Thank You members that's
agreed I shall now go to item one on the
agenda apologies for absence we have
received apologies members from
counselor mrs. Diane hi and councillor
Craig kennel does anybody know of any
others don't thank you item agenda to
declaration of interest are there any
declarations of interest to be noted
members
no thank you
agenda item three members have has been
withdrawn agenda item four report on
urgent decisions that is simply for
noting members agenda item five
allocation of seats on committees I
would like to invite the magic director
to present this report Thank You
chairman and good evening members the
report set so the methodology for
calculating the allocation of seats on
committees based on the composition of
the council based on the proposed
allocation of seats set out in appendix
one can I draw members attention to the
addendum to this item which sets
nominations for each for the 2020 the
recommendations with recommendation to
no be to the nominations Thank You mr.
Stratton I say any questions members
should when when you wish to speak
please click on the raised hand icon by
clicking on participants at the bottom
of your screen and clicking on the blue
raised hand icon at the bottom right of
the participants screen what I want you
to speak please unmute your microphone
and keep any speeches as concise as
possible please have always repeating
anything has already been said if you
want to refer to anything in reports
clearly the relevant page number and
paragraph number before you state any
points you wish to raise these mutual
microphone again when you have finished
speaking your blue raised hand icon
lowered by Sonja when you have finished
speaking counselor will concern you wish
to speak
Demming you please forgive me and I
actually wish to speak on the previous
item but I didn't get an opportunity to
because if you moved on even though I
raised my
and I didn't want to interrupt the
managing director when he spoke is it
not an opportunity chairman for us to
ask make comments on the previous item
so I thought that would be that has
already been put in place and is in full
force and effect and it's not up for
debate I'm afraid okay counselor Lucas
and I also indicated while item four you
mentioned it it may not be up to debate
and I don't think there's a debate
however the administration with an item
or have failed to put the actual urgent
decision and circulate that with the
minutes therefore well there's nothing
wrong with the fact that the urgent
decision was taken the actual decision
has not been circulated at that this
point in time and they note that we're
asked to no only gives reference to the
guidance not to the decision itself and
there is an issue we can't decision
where the managing director has
incorporated something that wasn't in
the original Constitution and certainly
I would like I realize we can't
retrospectively change it but it's due
for review on the first of June and I
would like that item which the managing
director is well aware of where he's
said that if a member does intend to
speak on a matter of business on the
agenda for a meeting of Council
Executive Committee prior notice must be
sent to the Member Services team by
midday on the day prior to the meeting
that's never been in our Constitution
before and I find it unacceptable to
have it added now and the technicality
we can't rectify decision that hasn't
been circulated mr. Chancellor mrs.
Mason can I say members that we are now
debating eight the debating item five
not the previous item mr. chairman thank
you you wish to speak on item five
please
express my frustration in not being
allowed to even speak on item the
previous item there is a issue with that
that I have which is quite important on
the document they've been put before us
well we haven't had a chance to
challenge it before but there is a
difference between the attachment that
was sent to us and the item that is
linked on the email that was sent to us
on the agenda with regards to the
reviewing on the first of June and it
needs clarity because the two are
different who is that speaking yes the
my step 10 members item 4 is for noting
only the issues to be raised outside of
this meeting please I cannot allow any
more discussion on item 4 we are
debating item 5 does anybody wish to
speak on item 5 please members there's
nobody else has indicated to wish to
speak on item 5 there are two
recommendations on page page of 5.2 of
the report one that the committees will
be consist constituents consisted of
situated as shown in Appendix 1 of a
report that members be appointed to
serve on committees for the 2020 21
minutes of year a set out and the
addendum to report on pages 5 11 to 5 14
I will now do a roll call of names for
the result for the vote would you please
indicate if you wish to vote for against
or abstain when you hear your names
counselor mrs. Belson
oh so counselor mrs. butcher Oh
counselor mr. Carter for counselor mrs.
Carter against myself counts to dry for
count lefty or counselor eaves for that
I'd like my vote recorded please it's
looking for a recorded vote some
counselor Gooding counselor Hazelwood or
council Hook way for mr. Hawaii for
counselor Hudson or counselor I Oh note
or skill or counselor Lumley counselor
mrs. Mason mr. chairman on a point of
order counselor Eve's asked how his vote
recorded he has every right to have that
recorded if he asked throwing of a
recorded vote the very are article for
which we haven't actually ratified says
that you will go around and ask and find
out if enough people want to recorded
vote so perhaps you could clarify with
calcineurin news asking for his folks we
record as a point of order hate you sir
the right to have you spoken corded a
recorded vote which should have been on
I started to take the vote of this item
with what you have put
the minutes that you have just approved
there is not in the guidance it says
that on the Royal Court if someone else
recorded vote
the officer will go round and see if
there is an O so the very thing that
you've actually saved that you will do
you're not doing would you please
clarify with Kelson reeves if he wanted
his note noted which he has every right
to have any way or if he was asking for
recorded vote
sorry it sorry to interject change so
Dave Kitson legal adviser just on that
point 70 rule seventeen point six or the
procedure rules so I am seventeen point
five gives a right for an individual
member to request immediately after the
vote is taken but will be recorded and
ministers to know whether they voted for
or against the motions so that there is
a right to do that but that rises
exercisable after the vote has been
taken okay thank you for that
clarification mr. mrs. Christie Mason
I'm against item five on how we are
going to request a recorded vote
because what you're doing now doesn't
approve the instructions that you sent
out or sent out by the managing director
so but as far as this folk goes going
for it but I would like that clarity at
the end of this vote please thank you I
will give you that clarity mrs.
Macpherson councillor Merrick or
councillor Milner or council Newport or
councillor Pavlin Oh counselor mrs. Rowe
Oh counselor mrs. Shaw or counselor mr.
Shaw for now Smith for counselor sparing
for counselor Stanley
that's a step toe or
councillor Ward or
council web for counselor mrs. Weston
Council Wilkinson for Thank You council
Williams or councillor Wilson or
councillor wooden or members that has
been passed in respect to the request of
councillor eaves for his vote to be
recorded that will be recorded in the
minutes
councillor mrs. Mason should you also
wish your vote to be recorded in the
minutes no I wanted clarity on is that
unfortunately the guidance notes and the
urgent decision by the managing director
circulated on 29th of April that stated
how voting was going to be taken has not
happened
so I'm now asking you to clarify how
mental
request we were told before that the
names would be read out and if a member
requested a recorded vote who knows
we've continued to be read out until
such time as the quorum for an Ellen
quite number which is a 20% was reached
yeah yeah clarity on the decision
manager that debating if and the
guidance notes that we have been given
are going to be conducted so that we
have clarity and we can understand how
to request a recorded vote because
unfortunately what is in writing is not
what's happened here tonight so far and
I just want that come the an
understanding so that going forward we
know where we are
I believe you microphone is turned off
mister Kitson could I ask you through a
view on that place yes sir of course
through you my understanding was that
the councillor requested that his
individual vote there is a rule under
17.4 where member can request well if
one fifth of the members present to be
taken down
I don't perhaps the councillor could
clarify what it was that he was asking
whether it was indeed as I understood it
a request for his individual vote to be
recorded or a request for the the entire
vote to be recorded in which case there
needs to be at least one fifth of those
presents in favor of that chair it would
have been for a recorded vote of the
whole Council which is what at the point
I was making mr. chairman in that the
regulations or whatever you like to call
them guidance notes or the urgent
decision by the managing director how
that spells out how this is done has not
been conducted so going forward I don't
know if CalSTRS wants that boat to be
taken again but also we need some
understanding for the next item how do
we request a recorded vote
easier how it was put in writing to all
campuses that as the names are called
success very clearly we have to ask
until the 20% of reach that has not been
done on this item and I leave it to you
and your advisers to work out how to
sort out this item but I wanted clarity
going forward before the next item is
debated Thank You mr. chairman
absolutely councillors could I ask you
to wait before speaking that I can allow
you to speak and keep muted in the
meantime councillor Eve's but I asked
you if you
can clarify whether you wanted your vote
recorded or a recorded vote my
understanding and mr. Kitson if you if
you think I'm wrong on this my
understanding is a request for recorded
valent must be made prior to me taking
the excuse me chairman I am sorry a
point of although I do appreciate the
debates going on I want to comment the
fact that I wasn't even asked to vote I
kept my apologies councillor Burton I
don't think it will change the outcome
but I've ticked you off well I wasn't
can I ask you if and we should take the
vote again or take the request for a
recorded vote I think given I mean it
obviously it's very difficult meetings
remotely isn't it misses testament to it
but I think perhaps chair it might be
worthwhile taking it again whether would
like for the votes be recorded Jamin
sorry - it's Carol Weston vice yeah I'm
sorry I can't see you no I keep I keep
losing the internet and I couldn't hear
what David kid summer saying half the
time either so I'm not I'm a bit
concerned that some of us are sort of
losing the Internet as this meeting is
going on which I seem to be doing as
well thank you chairman thank you can I
ask remind members to wait until I allow
them to speak before speaking counselor
mrs. Mason my understanding is that
voting will be done via roll call of
names if members want a recorded vote
they should have requested a recorded
vote before we start the roll call which
clearly wasn't done all right
counter Wilkins councillor Wilson you
wish to speak in that case mr. chip
sorry
that's a mrs. Christie Mason the Wilkin
Wilson you wish to speak Thank You
chairman can I just ask who mr. Tipton
is actually representing it was on his
screen it's showing up as bedroom
Britton LLP it's he actually
representing the council thank you yes
he's a deputy monitoring officer in the
absence of Angela law mr. Kitson can I
suggest that we take the vote again and
ask members to indicate whether they
wish their individual vote to be
recorded do you agree with that yes
chair I think it's sensible to take the
votes again but there is a slight
difference in in terms of the two rules
the first one being a request by at
least one fifth some members present for
all votes to be recorded the second rule
is about individual members stating
whether they want their own vote
recorded so if as I understand it now
and I think from the clarification that
was given by the councilor they were
requesting that it was a recorded vote
to cover all votes so I would suggest
that that's the way progresses in terms
of when you go through the roll call is
it the question is asked whether or not
the member supports that proposal for
there to be a recorded vote and if there
is of course a fifth of members who
support that then there would be the
recorded votes and it might also be
useful chair in the circumstances that
there isn't a full support for the
recorded vote or the 2001 fifth if you
like then each member might also just
mention whether in those circumstances
they would require their individual vote
to be recorded too and just to clarify
as well I am employed by Bevin Britain
we are a solicitor's firm independent of
the council we've been appointed to
provide legal support to the council
during the absence of the monitoring
officer and deputy monitoring officer
and myself and my colleague Judith
Barnes have been appointed as deputy
monitoring officers for that purpose on
a temporary basis so hopefully that
gives some clarity
Thank You mr. Kitson members I shall
come back to you shortly
members I'd like to make it clear wood
regards to the voting system in
respective revoked remote meetings the
council's a remote meeting state or
standing order states voting shall be
taken by a roll call of names of members
in remote attendance this is not a
recorded vote members if anyone requires
a recorded vote should be taken they
should ask for this before a roll call
of names is taken I will now call out
your name is in turn or if you wish to
have a recorded vote - there will be
members please
you
members shall read out an effort
alphabetical list of members who are
here this evening and could you please
indicate yes or no as to whether you
wish a recorded vote please
counselor Belton no councillor Burton
no counselor butcher no mrs. butcher
counselor mr. Carter now mrs. Carter yes
myself no count let FD know counselor
eat
yes but if you'd have actually allowed
me to speak I've had my hand up about
ten minutes you could have avoided all
this I'll come back to you cows leaves
counselor good chance the gaudiya muted
no now's the Hazlewood the hook way yes
counselor mr. hoy yes Hudson
no counselor IO knew no counsel Lucas
Gil no counselor mrs. Mason as it's
recorded already on YouTube better thank
you are staying mcpherson we're voting
where I'm asking if you want to recorded
vote on our chance to marry announce the
meal no how's the new port down sir mrs.
Waverly
now let me she's playin it's already
record it's already record - chairman I
don't see what we why we're doing this
so now Thank You counsel mr. Shah no
else mr. Shah
no Elsa Smith now now Suspiria
no no suspense Stanley yes we have a
sufficient number for recorded vote
there'll be a recorded vote members I
shall now go through the names once
again to ask you respect of your wish or
against abstain in respect of item five
members belton councillor Burton or
counselor mrs. butcher how's the missus
butcher mr. Carter for counselor mrs.
Carter for Chancellor myself counselor
dry for counselor ft Oh counselor
Eve's Oh counselor my sister for down to
the hook way for counselor mr. Hawaii
sorry um for counseling's to Hudson for
counselor IO new or a little crispy or
counselor mrs lammle counselor mrs.
Mason Oh counselor mrs. Macpherson or no
slim Eric
now's the meal or that's the Newport or
counselor mrs. Pavlin Oh counselor mrs.
Rowe for once the mrs. draw for down sir
mr. Shaw four counts of Smith Oh
countess pairing for Kamsa Stanley four
counts of Steptoe or
and as the ward or counsel web or mrs.
Weston oh I also wilkinson
this is mr. Wilkinson can you hear me
I can jamming yet did you hear me I
voted for Thank You counsel Williams or
counselor Wilson or counsel wooden
counsel button or Thank You members
that's been carried butchered can you
hear me yes I can now sorry against that
sorry for again I'm voting item 504
thank you
now once again that's been carried
members and is be recorded vote I don't
want to take any more questions in
respect us amen
that's why of order it's been carried
and then you ask for mrs. Butch's vote
yes because I've missed around the first
nine Scouts the Newport I thought it was
because here the connectivity problems
chairmen possibly come back if you
actually asked me right at the outset
when I put my hand up on this one we
could avoid it all this the problem is
that this was a bit of a test to see how
recorded vote would work and we've
obviously discovered a problem the
reason being why is because there are
more important item to follow up that we
will be asking for a recorded vote on
and this has just been a big waste of
time if you've actually got me to
actually speak I would have passed on
the fact that just for the point of
actually had been clarity on how we do
recorded voting in this system so it
would be handy in the future if you do
see her hands up please could you at
least acknowledge us thank you thank you
cows leaves I wasn't aware you wanted to
speak if I do where you wanted to speak
I would have let you speak 15 minutes
count Cerrone you wish to speak Thank
You chairman with all due respect we
shouldn't be testing people this is new
to everybody can we please just move on
we've got an important argent in time to
do with now can we just move on and get
on with it thank you
Thank You councillor ro Cal so mrs.
McPherson this is a last speaker I will
allow on this item at the start of the
meeting you asked us to raise our hands
the icon I would like to ask if it could
be reminded our fellow councillors not
to just jump in and then rehearse when
cows lease put his hand up you would
have noticed it I can see the side panel
too everyone seemed to have their hand
up so it can get confusing so rather
than jumping fellow councilors please
raise the hand icon thank you first if I
could remind everybody all members that
I wish to speak to a wait until I allow
them to speak before speaking members
will now take item six on the agenda the
report from the executive and committees
to Council this came to us by the
investment board by their meeting on the
17th of March 2020 I will invite
councilor Mike Steptoe to introduce this
item
there's chairman of the investment board
councilor Steptoe yes thank you chairman
as chair of the investment board I'm
pleased to bring this report to Council
with a recommendation for approval as
set out on page six point one of the
report the asset delivery program brings
life to the council's exciting and
ambitious exit strategy
the strategy has the following
objectives reduce costs to regenerate
the local area and provide fit for
purpose office accommodation the
objectives are more relevant now than
they have ever been and as a
forward-thinking council I am pleased
that we have a clear strategy in place
to deliver these objectives at its
meeting at its meeting in March the
Investment Board received a detailed
presentation setting out the robust
process that had been undertaken work
culminated with the Investment Board
recommending to council that the
recommendations within the report to be
approved I please therefore to propose
council approve the recommendations or
page 6.1 of the report this will will
enable the final contract to be
negotiated and brought back to the
council for approval and provide
commercial certainty to the preference
preferred peer finally I would it it
will be necessary to move into private
and confidential
in order to main commercially sensitive
to maintain commercially sensitivity
when did debating the the report and
detail officers have provided private
and confidential sites slide deck with
all members should have received the
summaries are detailed take the desk
that summarizes the detail tender report
and the fire financial business case in
order and to ensure concise presentation
offices will highlight and address the
key slides within their presentation in
order to enable officers to present the
information can I ask to you chairman
that the questions
be taken at the end of the presentation
I would like to thank the member working
group for the kashin enthusiasm and
enthusiasm they they brought to this
program Thank You chairman I would now
like to invite the portfolio holder to
comment on his involvement in the
program Thank You councillor Steptoe
council woodman Thank You chairman and
if I may
can I reserve my right to speak later in
the debate but of course I'm very happy
to second the proposal Thank You
councillor wooden chairman sorry I'm not
sure if he was speaking to us but what I
could see you speaking to somebody but
you're muted council spurring could I
ask you to address the meeting
yes thank you chairman I had a similar
problem to councillor Wilkinson I'm
afraid chairman members I would like to
read this statement on behalf of the
council members that were working in the
asset delivery program working group in
support of the council officers
comprehensive statement regarding the
asset delivery program which will be
presented shortly I offer this statement
on behalf of the council members who
supported and were involved in the
working group in 2018 assets strategy
agreed to do nothing ie just keep on
going as we are now with a minimum of
investment was not an option when faced
with an increasing midterm financial
strategy budget gap and they are
continuing commitment to revive value
for money so so
is to our residents the outlined
business case identified that the
preferred option was more economically
advantageous than a do minimum option
since the council would be exposed to
costs of running and maintaining the
mill arts and events center and the
freight house when the leisure contract
ends in 2022
plus the costs of repairing and
maintaining the aging Civic suite and
South Street offices the preferred
option agreed in the outline business
case proposed a reprogram to regenerate
projects to a redevelop the freight
house as the council's long term office
accommodation and civic space be
redeveloped the mill site to create a
new building community facility
alongside housing and commercial or
mixed-use and see redevelop sale Street
sites and the Civic suite for housing
commercial on Mir excuse the preferred
option was set out in the outline
business case which was approved by the
Investment Board on the 16th of January
2019 and then by fall council on the
19th of February 2019 the council then
began began a procurement process to
explore how sediba the preferred option
the council members on the working group
have been a fundamental part of the
process which was set up under specific
terms of reference to work with officers
professional advisors and the portfolio
holder to speed this project through at
the start of this project it hoped there
would be cross-party involvement in the
working group but this regrettably
was not accepted and only myself
councillors FD Lukas Gill and Williams
served on the committee sorry on the
group as a group we have had to work
through very strict legal procurement
process which has been completely new to
many of us and at times was very
frustrating but this progress this
process
strictly followed the treasure the
Treasury best practice we also brought
in external expertise which have
included experts in the field of project
management legal financial and technical
these experts have worked fully with
officers and the members of the working
group in February 2019 our little
partnership health check review reviewed
and endorsed our approach and validated
the decisions taken to date at that time
we have also had additional insurance
through the east of England
LGA who were commissioned specifically
to provide critical friend support to
the member working group and have been
part of the procurement process
throughout the member working group is
confident that the process has been
lynda member led and has been robustly
managed we have confidence in the
solutions which have been put for by the
preferred bigger we can't talk about the
specifics of the situation until meeting
the meeting moves to PNC but we believe
that as a member working group we have
done all that was asked of us all key
decisions have been passed through us
and then into formal council governance
at investment board or full Council or
both finally there is still more legal
process to be completed once this is
done the member working group has been
clear that the council will begin to
engage with the public and stakeholders
such as the use of the buildings about
the proposals the procurement process
the council specified that the preferred
bidder work with us to ensure that this
period of engagement is wide-ranging a
meaningful we've wanted to know what
residents think of the solutions and
hear what feedback they have want to
give us all this will be done in part in
advance of the formal planning
consultation so there is a real
opportunity to influence the final
proposals the members of the working
group are happy to talk more detail
about the preferred bidders solution
but we must move into PNC to do that as
I mentioned earlier much of this process
has been very frustrating for members of
the working group because we have not
been permitted to answer questions from
both fellow councillors and residents
but it is very important that it
continues to stay
PNC until the legal process has been
completed otherwise the entire
procurement process could be jeopardized
leaving the council exposed to
potentially huge legal claims that's it
chairman thank you very much thank you
counts of sparing members are shown now
our sonia to stop the public livestream
so that the council's officers mr.
Harwood white and Miss Lucas can give us
a presentation which will include
commercially sensitive information for
any resident mm to this meeting on the
live screen stream the livestream will
be temporary suspended for exempt
presentation however the livestream will
be restarted afterwards and a decision
taken on this report can be viewed once
a live stream is restarted